are you a fan of debate no tell me why
because debate implies
that a person
the person who wins a debate is often
the person who is more charismatic or is
a better Communicator wow that typically
happens especially in politics
and if it's a pure matter of opinion
then a person should just simply have
their opinion if it's a matter of
objective truths that should be no
debate about it at all it's not about
debate it's here's the evidence now
let's make the decision so for me
debating is is
all about
grandstanding and idea
rather than arriving at an actual
solution so to be fair you should win
100 of the debates no I don't enter
debates but what I'm saying is if the if
the
if the argument is a person who is
better at presenting arguments could oh
oh I could validate a point better than
somebody that you're an incredible uh it
should not depend on that Talent of a
person to decide what is or is not true
in a debate
really so so of course not oh my gosh no
no I'm really good at saying you know
the sky is green now let me debate that
with you and I have a Charisma and
everyone said votes and they say and I
win the debate that doesn't make the sky
green even if I won the debate that's an
exaggeration I get what you're saying
but I mean if that would have been the
case then the last election Biden
shouldn't have won because he's horrible
he's made maybe one divorce on the
history of debates on National
Television yes all I'm saying is that
often a debate is one on Charisma I
don't disagree more than it is on the
counter enough that a b
if a if an if an if it subject can be
objectively analyzed
then it does not benefit from a debate
see
if it's a matter of opinions
who you want to vote for because you
prefer one policy or another
have the debate
go ahead
that's the only kind of debate I would
enter but I don't care if anyone else
has my opinions yeah I would say I'm not
going to try to convince you of my
opinions I got you well opinion is one
thing but for example like Nixon to me
and Biden are the same the moment Nixon
had to debate on the national you know
the story yeah we kind of yeah with
Canada it was like a bad situation
because right Kennedy looked good he was
10 he slapped all this stuff and no he
had makeup on yeah makeup on all this
stuff and the other he didn't shape
anyways but but here's where I'm kind of
going with this during cold by the way
we forget that was one of the closest
elections in American history yeah well
anyone watching on TV I wasn't alive
then but I've studied it anyone watching
on TV thought that JFK won no but anyone
watching or listening on radio thought
Nixon won correct because
it all tells you the debate construct is
like what what are you doing here okay I
mean that's that's the American system
when it comes down to that but there's a
part of me that agrees that's my
debating opinions yeah I'm just not
going to do it because I don't care if
anyone else has it okay so let me ask
I'm not against it yeah I'm just saying
and and my school had a really good
debate team right I'm embarrassingly old
am I 30 at the point I learn that
competitive debate teams it's when you
enter the debate tournament you do not
know
in advance what side you're going to
argue
and you're handed aside to argue and I
thought to myself really
oh my gosh so you're just a trained
arguer that's what you are and then
these are people become attorneys and
attorneys become the greatest source of
presence in Congress so we have people
who are trained arguers trying to arrive
at an agreement on anything it's I'm
surprised anything ever works in
Congress at all are you for scientific
debate
so in a scientific debate here's how
that unfolds I'm in conversation with
you but let's call it a debate we know
you and I know walking into that room
either I'm right and you're wrong okay
you're right and I'm wrong or we're both
wrong
we know that in advance so we start
having the conversation well what about
these data what about these I think
those datas are flawed and here's why
well how about this yes that's a debate
but you know how that debate ends it
depends where you know we need this new
data set to resolve this difference
now let's go have a beer
I have never seen that happen in a
political debate
I've never seen nor with two lawyers in
a courtroom you know I never thought
about it that way good idea I concede
has that ever happened I think the
answer to that is no and so so because
one lawyer says wow you convinced me of
that no if you see a debate on
television will one ever just concede to
the other wow you I've never thought
about it that way yeah no they're in it
for the win whether or not they're right
yeah and I can't go there so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]